it perhaps isn't clear from the JPEG
video when JPEG isn't a good idea I mean
a lot of people say oh you should never
use JPEG for scientific images or
something like that because it Thoth is
totally lost lossy compression you're
going to lose those a quality and that
is true but it's also not in a sense
that you're prying it's lossy
compression a very very small image
blocks so you won't get coherence
between one block and the next but it'll
look pretty good and for most imaging
that's okay obviously lots of people
swear by shooting in RAW and you know
good luck to JPEG uses up a lot less
space and and so for most practical
purposes a JPEG image is fine one time
where JPEG images are not fine is text
most people will have spotted JPEG
artifacts that is specular bits of image
around text and maybe not quite
understood why that's there apart from
it's just a side effect of JPEG
compression well specifically it's a
side effect of JPEG compression on text
because text violates our assumptions
that high frequency information doesn't
contribute a lot to the image so this is
a small 8 by 8 image that I've come up
with the illustrators purpose so this is
this is in a sense text this is the
computer file see it's little triangular
brackets it's 8 by 8 that's not the
highest resolution but it serves our
purpose quite well one thing that this
image has that our last image of the
flower didn't have is sharp changes in
intensity so this C has a sharp step
down into the background and that it's
not something that JPEG handles very
well at all if we look at the encoded
luminosity block of if we get this so
this is our C represented as just naught
to 255 luminosity values so these are
our background ones of about 48 this is
our C here and our brackets here each of
these represents the grayscale intensity
of that corresponding pixel in our 8 by
8 image now if we were encoding this in
JPEG what we would then do is we would
shift all these and we will calculate
our DCT coefficients and then we would
get rid of the high frequency ones and
we would encode them and in doing so we
would massively compress the image at
what we assumed to be a pretty
reasonable quality but this that isn't
true in this case if we look at the DCT
coefficients you can see that our
assumption that the big ones are always
in the top-left sort of the
low-frequency contributes molten image
is hugely violated this particular
coefficient
for example only contribution or point
eight that was I think a value of two
hundred or something in our last video
down here we have big big coefficients
thirty sixty seven point five and
fifty-three minus fifty three all in
these really high frequency cosine waves
so if we look at our logo coefficients
next to our DCT we can see that what
we've essentially got is a lot of this
one here so that's this one so this C
has a lot of this particularly
contribution which you can kind of see
because there is a kind of C shape in it
and so it's hard to it's hard perhaps to
grasp that the exact contribution groups
will have because these coefficients
have essentially arbitrary numbers but
the point is that this image is the
addition of lots of these high-frequency
sections and a lot less of these low
frequency ones so when we do our
standard quantization we're going to
divide all of these numbers by huge
amounts and set most of them to zero and
that's going to be a big problem
because when we then recreate the image
on the other side we're going to find
that what was vital in recreating this
image has now gone and we're not going
to get it back and in fact that's
exactly what you do see so if we show
the actual output here we can see that
our C is kind of visible but it's been
completely dwarfed by all this random
noise that's been added to the edge of
our text and this is exactly what
happens in normal compression of text
using JPEGs essentially we assume just
like in normal nature photographs that
we can get rid of the high frequency
information and we couldn't do that that
was a bad idea and so we've got all this
stuff that we shouldn't have if we look
at the block when compared to the
original we can see that this value with
48 is now 66 so a lot of these values
have changed by quite a large amount in
our last video I think the standard
error between the old and the new was
something like three on average they
changed about three up or down this is
about eleven it's over triple the amount
of sort of average error that we're
getting on our pixels and because it's
text we can see that very clearly in the
output image so the solution to this
really is not to use JPEG when you've
got a huge amount of text bearing in
mind that I shrank that C down to fit
into one 8 by 8 block in actual fact you
would have if you had like a sign you
were taking a picture of a street sign
you would find that a letter took up a
huge amount of image and so maybe you're
already compressing one small edge of it
and it won't
so bad but certainly if you're
compressing your JPEG with texting it at
50% or lower quality you're going to
start to see a JPEG artifacts where
because these high frequencies have been
moved you get kind of speckles where
they would have dialed that down you
might have seen actually if you load up
a poorly compressed text document but
when you zoom in it doesn't scale well
and that's why e meters won't use
something like this felled try amend of
a text sort of from source as it were
and that way they don't have any of
these problems the interesting thing is
that once this damage is done it doesn't
make it worse to keep me encoding it
because the the coefficients for this
are now all 0 as because we've set them
to 0 if we read encoder this as a JPEG
it's not going to get progressively
worse unless we change the quality
settings it's actually just going to
stay this bad so essentially this is a
bad JPEG of all version of this which
you should stick to if you want to keep
using JPEG but otherwise avoid it
absolutely useless in almost any other
domain if you put a chess AI in a Google
self-driving car not only can it not
drive the car it doesn't have the
concept doesn't know what a car is